hi guys welcome to the stress webinar
i'm excited to share
this very valuable information with you
just because
number one i know what it's going to do
to your physical body
and number two the amount of people that
are walking around with
stress is just like off the charts okay
this is not us a webinar
about sitting in a mountain top doing
meditation it's not a webinar to give
you a bunch of
things that may reduce your stress a
little bit it's not a seminar that is
going to handle any of your
actual root
uh life problems it's mainly
focused on extracting
the physical stress that is stuck in
your body right now okay
what you have to realize is all stress
is accumulative
um
all stress physical and mental stress
some people have had a lot of stress in
your life other people
really had no stress it's kind of
interesting i i don't really meet these
people that have no stress but there's
some i had this one guy for example
he um
used to be a rodeo clown okay
so he would be
fighting with these bowls
okay then he decided to join the marines
and you know how stressful that is to go
through basic training
so anyway he was in combat he jumped out
of the plane his chute didn't open
um he hit the trees he survived he
fractured his back
he got caught
held hostage for i think 30 days
tortured okay here's a guy who has
basically
massive amount of physical stress
massive blood pressure because he's been
through a lot other people
have not had stress
so number one you have to realize that
stress is accumulative
mental stress kind of sticks on your
body physical trauma surgeries injury
stick to the body
so what we're going to do is i'm going
to show you
how to extract that stress if you scan
your body right now and just kind of
feel
for stress like is the stress located in
your head
is it your neck is it in your jaw
and your upper back
is it in the mid back the lower back
uh the inside of your chest cavity is it
in your abdomen
where is your stress right now
make mental note because we're going to
come back to that i'm going to show you
on quite a few people
just to demo this
exactly how to do it and there's
different techniques
to extract stress i isolate the key
areas in your body that tend to be the
epicenters of stress and then i
developed a technique of how to get rid
of it and you're going to learn it okay
it would be good if you had a partner
watching this okay if you had someone to
practice this practice on back and forth
if not that's fine because i am going to
show you the do-it-yourself version you
will need a tool like this
um
it comes with the manual so you don't
have to memorize anything also if you
take people that are gaining weight okay
there's always a point where they start
gaining weight and so many people start
gaining weight after a stress event okay
whether it's pregnancy hysterectomy even
a tonsillectomy and menopause these
stressors can kick in and affect the
body
big time okay
also think about the last time you were
sick
i will bet you anything there was some
stress that occurred just before that
that lowered your resistance and set you
up for getting an infection
it's an area that people don't look at
what's involved is the adrenal glands
adrenal glands sit on top of the kidney
you have two of them they're the glands
that react and adapt to stress
whether it's increasing your pulse rate
turning things on turning things off
running adrenaline
so if you are under a lot of stress over
many many years the adrenal glands can
then wear out and then you have a lot of
issues so the main stress hormone that
is created by the adrenal glands is
called cortisol
cortisol i've done a lot of videos on
this i'm not going to give you a lot of
data all you need to know is that
a lot of people have a constant high
level of cortisol they don't know it and
if the cortisol is too high you have a
whole bunch of symptoms a lot of blood
sugar issues too and if the cortisol is
too low you have a whole set of
additional symptoms so if you want to
find out more information about that you
can search
my youtube channel so when the
accumulation of stress starts building
more and more and more what happens
you're going to find that you're going
to be very busy in your head excessively
thinking solving problems 24 7
very busy it might feel nervous
anxious
worry you're solving problems you're
fixated on problems so in a given day
you can have everything go right but one
problem and all your attention is stuck
on that one problem so eventually it
will cause a lack of focus and attention
and concentration okay they call that
add where your attention is not on
something you're thinking about over
here over here and it's hard to focus
you have to realize your power your
ability to complete things is your
attention so the more stress you have
the more it can really affect your your
productivity
you'll get brain fog then you need
caffeine you need coffee so recently i
was at a grocery store and i looked
across the street there's a starbucks
there was a line all the way around the
building and this was like in the
afternoon so there's a lot of people
drinking a lot of coffee to stay awake
and they probably all have adrenal
issues too
also it's going to eventually affect
your tolerance to stress
your ability to tolerate
incompetent people will be a problem
insanities they're going to rub you the
wrong way so that's really a good
indication of how well your adrenals are
of how tolerant you are
to life if you can't tolerate then your
adrenals aren't that great
over time if cortisol stays high you end
up getting a lot of conditions a lot of
blood sugar issues
diabetes because cortisol turns your
muscle into sugar you get inflammatory
conditions like arthritis high
cholesterol high blood pressure
osteoporosis
all sorts of health issues now there's a
test that i used to do in my office
called heart rate variability and it
measures um
how much stress is in a body and it's
fascinating because i have people come
in and look at this graph they're so
stuck in stress mode and i wouldn't even
have to ask them if they're stressed i
would say wow you're stressed out and
they go wow how do you know now if that
needle is
up and down perfectly level
then their body is not in stress mode
and i would also say that and they go
yeah how do you know how did you know
that my machine measures how much stress
you have in your body and we can we can
pick it up so when i mentioned technique
i'm talking about a technique that i'm
going to teach you right now of how to
extract stress from the body and i would
use this as a before and after to see
the change one of the biggest things
that this technique is going to help you
with is to improve your quality of sleep
sleep is everything it's going to help
you cope with stress it's going to help
you rejuvenate it's going to increase
your tolerance for stress in fact you
cannot heal the adrenals without sleep
it's impossible how you're going to get
rid of sleep problems if you have stress
and i'm talking about a cumulative
stress in your body so so yes we need to
go for long walks we need to get space
we need to eat better the first
technique we're going to show you is how
to get rid of stress in your neck okay
so that's going to be a very cool
technique and there's different points
in the neck that we're going to work on
and then we're going to work on the
points in the mid-back and then the
abdomen area then in the upper part of
the rib cage where a lot of people hold
a lot of stress so with that let's get
right to it and show you how to do this
technique
okay so we're going to show you how to
pull stress out of the body the first
technique is the called the upper
cervical now
what you're going to do is you're going
to take this is meant to be done on
someone else so hopefully you have a
twin or a partner you can do this i'm
going to show you how to do it to
yourself but this is great to do it on
someone else okay so you want to use
this finger here this one i'm not
flipping you off this is
this is just the middle finger right
here and then your thumb okay and then
we're going to press this way
right underneath her skull
and the most important thing is not to
mess up your hair yeah okay so we're
gonna there's this little ridge right
underneath the skull
you're gonna slip right underneath it
and you're gonna press in equally okay
and you're gonna take your hand and
press on the forehead so you're gonna
press in
right like this you feel that
and the key is to make sure that you're
equal like the thumb and the middle
finger the pressure so you're not too
much of one side
now what i'm doing now is i'm
stimulating
something in your neck
that is triggering
the kind of the
the brake pads or the it's called the
parasympathetic nervous system which is
the relaxation
points in the body
and the parasympathetic nervous system
that comes out at this level
of your spine
kind of helps you sleep it helps you
relax
and so that's why the more that i do
this the more that
you're going to feel like you want to
take a nap how does it feel so far
you're going to go to sleep i thought so
so um i'm just pressing in right
underneath that and i'm just going to
hold that for about an hour
no just kidding
but if i keep doing this she's going to
feel very relaxed so this is like the
real key de-stressor point it's going to
pull the stress right out of your body
now i'll do this for a little bit maybe
for like a minute and then i'll slip
down to the second
vertebra right here
this one is really good for sinus
issues
so do you have any sinus issues
did you want any sinus okay good so the
sinus points it just helps you breathe
and it's good for people that have sleep
apnea so again i'm just pressing my
fingers in this way and the head that
way okay
so i'm going to come right in there
all right and then i'll slowly kind of
come down and i'm looking for
tightness if there's no tightness i'm
not going to press on it now when i come
down to the third vertebra
on her left side there's a big knot it's
tight so what i'll do is i'll just press
a little more towards the left side and
it's going to make her neck feel really
good it's going to put the curve back in
the neck so i'm just going to creep down
lower and lower until i get right here
this is a c5
this one is really good if you have a
sore throat
or a raspiness like your your voice is
hoarse
let's say you're a musician you like you
sing or you
um
speak for a living and your voice is
kind of raspy you do this and it kind of
opens up the
the voice
now um
do you feel this point how tight this is
right here yeah yeah
so i'm just holding this pressure until
it melts
okay
i'm not pressing that hard and then now
i'm going to go all the way down very
lower like to the lower points that's
this is c6
this is really good for um
the thyroid thyroid points but what i'm
going to do is i'm going to hold this
until the entire neck is nice and loose
and she's going to feel very relaxed in
the neck so many people hold stress in
the neck
okay look at right through in there you
feel this point right here so i'm
emphasizing the left side because it's
it's kind of really tight on the left
okay so how does that feel good you like
that yeah okay good so you can
let's uh let's get the next victim i
mean the next patient
and i'm just going to show you example
several examples
okay good so this is great because um
now we can actually see what we're doing
again here's her skull i'm going to slip
right down up underneath
her skull right through in here and yeah
we have some tightness here
so this is a good one
i'm sorry
i didn't mean to invalidate you but
okay relax your head
i want to get directly underneath her
skull
so i'm going to press right in there as
you can see this right here
and tell me what that feels like
good
yeah so the thing that you want to focus
on is basically um
doing it equal
because you don't want to just put more
pressure on one side unless it's tighter
okay relax your head
now the only time you wouldn't want to
do this
like this
is let's say they had a
car accident
have you ever had a car accident no okay
good
and they were rear-ended
and their neck went like this
way back like this
and then now here i am putting their
neck in the same motion that's not going
to be good so for that one you'd want to
do the opposite you want to stretch the
other way
okay so tell me what you're feeling
right now when i do that
it feels good
no pain or anything does it give any
relaxation through any part of the body
yeah you're going to feel like a
calmness down the entire spine so now
i'm going to come down the second one
the third one would actually handle
hiccups if you have this
hiccup have you ever had hiccups
yes okay
well
you don't have one right now do you no
okay darn it i wanted to show you if you
press on this
point it tends to clear it up
okay so now i'm on this point right here
this is pretty tight do you feel that
so i'm a little bit lower in her neck
but
i think she's gonna sleep really good
tonight
but um
again
you have to just find out where the
person is holding their tension
and uh clear that out
um
yeah right there good all right good how
does that feel now great do you feel
relaxed
great okay good so you can we're going
to get the next victim now we're going
to do another point that's very very
important and this one
there's a little muscle underneath the
collar bone okay this is the collar bone
called the clavicle and you have these
little muscles underneath here
no one ever works on these muscles ever
and it's a source of a lot of tension
especially if you're sitting all day and
your posture is bad
but what we want to do is you want to
hook the finger up underneath these two
bones
and have her lift her head back
all the way back all the way back back
back back back stretch it back and i'm
lifting up on the collarbone okay and we
so i'm spreading my hands out and then
inward like this okay go back
good go forward
go back
good forward
and i'm lifting up as i'm pressing in
okay
and what will happen is she'll be able
to tilt her neck all the way back after
doing that in fact doing this will
totally melt the neck in so many
different cases
so
which one of you have it has a stiff
neck
let me just let me just borrow you so
thanks for coming up give you a lot of
examples how to do this
okay so tilt your head back okay good
good forward
now
okay so i'm going to go back
forward
back
forward okay so now tilt your head back
oh it's not
did it just crack yeah
okay so go ahead and tilt it back now
let's see how is it any looser yeah it
is but it's like i can go further go
further
yeah so if you keep doing this you'll be
able to have us turn his head actually
at 365 degrees but yeah so we heard a
little snap in there
which
just kind of happens sometimes um okay
well thank you for coming up good have a
seat right here all right so then we're
gonna have let's have roxanna come up so
now that you know how to do the clavicle
point
now we're gonna do
something really cool
and we're going to do the mid back
it's for people that sit and slouch
a lot
and don't sit up tall
and basically in the mid back you have
something called the sympathetic nervous
system okay that's the flight or fight
that's the stress
part of the activation of the nervous
system that helps you counter stress and
it's from the top of the upper back
to kind of almost to the lower part okay
and there's this ligament on the front
part of the vertebra on the inside
that's really tight with a lot of people
so we're going to stretch that out so
when we're done
not only is she going to be you know
very
good posture but she's going to feel
very relaxed okay so we're going to take
take your first finger and your thumb
like this
okay see that right there
and then we're going to take this and i
like to grab the shoulder but make sure
you don't like
press
down here too because it might be sore
but go ahead and tilt your head back
now go forward
good and back and i'm pressing
and i'm pulling her body over
this pivot point and i'm keeping
this part straight and my elbow is
tucked into my body so i'm not like this
because i'm like if i did like this tilt
should back be like oh this is like a
lot of work right i'm going to keep my
body
directly behind her
put this right in the center and have
her do the work stretch over this point
it's kind of like a leverage point good
come back
[Music]
this one it feels really good it's
important
it's a little hard to do if someone's
really big
but um
just have them do it stretch right over
your okay now the thing about roxanna is
like she's not
not too stiff so you might feel a little
more relaxed but you're in pretty good
shape good thank you let's uh let's
bring our friend up here first um which
seems to respond really good
so
so again we're going to take this right
here
i'm going to take this and press back
like tilt head back over
good go forward
back
good
and back
i'm going to show you how to do this to
yourself with a device in a little bit
oh
did it snap again
there's no
no extra charge for that okay
okay good
so he's really loose right here so again
i'm not going to spend a lot of time if
it's
not tight but you should see how tight
some people are
okay so
how did that feel
feel relaxed i felt it in my ears oh did
you yeah
that's awesome no extra charge for that
too good see right here
all right so let's have you come up here
okay good so we're going to take my hand
here and we're going to tilt the head
back yeah good go forward
and then back
good and then back
and then back all the way stretch
stretch stretch have her do the work
okay come back yep that's right don't
let him cheat okay
right there good
normally i'm used to working on really
stiff people
you guys are not too bad
okay good
how does that feel good feels good
doesn't it okay great have a seat so
that's how you do the mid back okay all
right we saved the best for last okay so
what we're going to do
these points are
a problem for everyone um the the
adrenal glands are
deep very deep on top of the kidney deep
in the abdomen okay so we're not we
there's no way we can contact the
adrenals however there's a lot of
acupressure points around this there's a
lot of nerve points around the adrenals
in this area and in chinese medicine
there's acupressure points that
go right along the side we're going to
be kind of tapping into that and
releasing a lot of the stress in this
area around the adrenal so her belly
button
is right here okay so we're going to
just go right to
the right of it her right
and down about an inch and we're going
to press down in here now this is i'm
showing you how to do it on someone else
but we're going to show you how to do it
on yourself so i like to take my thumb
and my middle finger again i'm not put
i'm not flipping you off
and i'm going to press down in here to
her tolerance and i'm actually trying to
find some tenderness this isn't too bad
so if i don't feel any tenderness i'm
going to kind of sneak up a little bit
and i'm going to do all these points up
on this line about an inch off the
midline okay so we're going to come in
here
press in here and i'm going to go to the
left and to the right a little bit just
to kind of find these
stress pockets
okay see if i can find these yeah she
has a couple right here and then once i
find it i'll just hold it for a little
bit until it releases and what i'm doing
is i'm extracting
stress from this area of your body and
this produces some really
cool effects
relaxation
sleep like i've had people had the best
sleep in their life so this is a really
important area of the body that like no
one works on
so now as i'm coming up to the right
side
you do have the gallbladder on the right
side but that's kind of tucked through
this area you're not going to it's not
going to be a problem when you press on
that you just have to press
to the tolerance of the person so you're
not going to
um deep because it could be sore
again we're that's why i like to have
you do this on yourself so you can
adjust the pressure so you're not
uh you know going too
deep so
some people say well is it dangerous to
press in your abdomen i'm like
no why would it be was it dangerous to
press in your muscle in your thigh i
mean
you have a layer of fat okay and you
also have i didn't mean to say that
everyone has like a layer of fat and
then the organs are tucked in there with
a lot of connective tissue
and um i've been doing this for like 29
years
and
it's not a problem it's pretty safe
get in there but like you massage your
muscles but how many times do you work
on the the muscles in your in your your
abdomen like rarely and some of the
organ like the kidneys and the liver
points i mean people never work on these
points but i'm coming through here
right up through and here on this side
and i do find some
some tension
i'm just going to press on that a little
bit until it releases
and of course
i'm going a little bit faster than i
normally would because
sometimes i'll spend maybe two or three
minutes just on the right side
how does that feel
good does it feel uncomfortable no okay
good so now i'm going to go to the
opposite side
and press on that now if the person has
low back pain
what you do is you press on the exact
opposite side on the front
bam gone so you want to find out where
it's hurting in the back make like just
draw a line right through it and press
in the front it gets rid of a little
back pain like that
so on everyone you're going to find like
one or two points that are really really
tight
and then you'll work on those
more aggressively
so i'm going to press them here and just
kind of work that out
and
and some people it'll be very very
tender so you want to go kind of light
on them
some people have a lot they have a huge
belly you can still do this but
you will because you're working on the
superficial points
more than anything
that connect because an acupressure
point do you know an acupressure point
is
okay
an acupressure point is an area on the
surface of the skin that kind of
connects on the inside
you have all these electrical circuits
so it's kind of like a switchboard i can
press this point and it can affect
inside
does that make sense
yeah are you sure
are you falling
are you good so it's working
so um
so a lot of these are nerve points
kind of you can look them at like nerve
points because they really are so
um acupressure points are communication
channels
if you if you take a look at the nervous
system being the freeway the acupressure
points are the side roads so they're
just other forms of communication that
you can
affect
like right through and here this is a
good one
and you if you think about the last time
you were stressed
i will guarantee you have a lot of
tension in your abdomen after that and
you'll feel like why is it so hard in
them because you have the adrenaline the
adrenals pumping a lot of hormones and
then it tightens up all the muscles you
start working on that it gets rid of
stress so what we're doing now is we're
handling
she's sleeping now we're handling
physical stress that is stuck in your
body
for years i mean probably what 30 years
35 years yeah right
now you have some people that have never
experienced stress in their life and i'm
like if you live on planet earth and
other people have experienced a
tremendous amount
but if i keep doing this and i'm just
holding these pressure points like i'm
trying to keep
a broad content i'm not like up
like like look at how wide my thumb is
okay i have huge thumbs so that comes in
handy
so um
but if you have this little tiny thumb
that could be it's like sticking a
little thing in there it could irritate
the area so you want to keep a broad
contact almost like take your two
fingers and kind of separate them out
and press in there
and
okay good
good
so now you ready for a nap
okay good so let's bring the next person
up thank you very much
okay so um just relax your arms right
here uh where's your belly button
right here okay
so we're gonna just start and again
one inch off the midline
taking my two fingers and you can use
your thumb
or several fingers to equal the size of
the thumb if you have uh
if you don't have a thumb like mine
and come right in there and we're just
going to work out he has some tension in
here um have you ever experienced stress
before
it's just no no no okay
it's a new concept for people but uh
um
right through there so we're just gonna
press in there and again i'm watching
the eyeballs to make sure they don't pop
out because i don't want to press too
hard
and then so each time i do this i might
do it a couple times a week or maybe
once a week each time i do this
i'm going to feel like less and less
tension to the point where
i go right in there and like there's
nothing there's no resistance
so that's the goal
so
if you can do it on yourself i would do
it every night before you go to bed
i'm going fast for time
but i wanted to see if there's any
let's see right through and there that's
a ton of a tight spot right there
okay now i'm going to do the opposite
side
if the right side is not sore chances
are the opposite side will be sore it's
always going to be one or the other so
if you find that there's like one or two
points that's all that you find that's
constantly sorted those are the points
that you're going to focus on
so that's just kind of an example now
let's say he was going to do it to
himself
he'd use this torture i mean treatment
device and
it has these longer prongs and the
shorter ones you want to use the long
one you'd want to have him
grab the tool
and now we're going to position
this
this little thing right on this point
okay so i want you to kind of press just
like
like i like you felt me doing it
and tell me if you can feel the same
kind of pressure yeah feel that
that's really like moving up well yeah
just start start with one point and just
press in in there
does it feel similar yeah it does okay
and the reason why it feels similar is
because i developed this tool after my
thumb
for myself
because
like i was the last guy to get
treatments
i never got treatment so i'm like i'm
going to do it myself so i developed
this device that mimics my hand because
we're going to show you the neck points
as well
um
and we just come in here and then he
would before he goes to the bed right
he's in his bed
he's puts this point on there let's
and try to actually get through all of
it without falling asleep but by the
time he gets all the way to the top i
mean so many times i'll wake up and i'm
like oh wow where's that device it's
right next to me i almost rolled on it
like i literally fall asleep
while i'm doing this because it's
releasing
a lot of stress
is it creating any effect on you yet
yeah it's very comfortable yeah it's
interesting um how it gives people so
much relief
i think because you have the kidneys in
there you have the solar plexus which
are all these nerve connections you have
all these connections to the adrenal
points
you have the gallbladder the digestion
um
you probably have you heard of the
flight or fight mode
have you ever heard of the firefight
okay it's called the sympathetic nervous
system that's like
the stress mode
then you have another system
and i'm going to give you this
big word it's called enteric and that's
part of the
the system that's below your awareness
that actually runs all your digestion
and
that's really another system that we're
tapping into right now we're actually
stimulating it to
relax
a lot of stuff that's going on in your
gut nerve wise can affect your head
like if you ate the wrong thing and you
feel bloated you're going to feel funky
in the head how many of you experienced
that
yeah
so
your digestion can affect
your mood
big time there's a connection
so when you release the tension in your
gut especially if you have like ibs or
irritable bowel syndrome or inflammation
that creates like spasms it gives you a
lot of relief in the head
now when we come up to these points
right through in here like on his right
side it's a little sore right yeah so
now you adjust the pressure so it's just
right for you
he's hitting something called the
phrenic nerve that goes right up to his
diaphragm up to the right neck he's
going to release all the right neck
tension so the more he does this point
here he's going to have like less
tension on the right side up here
even like headaches will go away on the
right side shoulder stuff so anything
right here will melt this side right
here
if he does the other side
he'll actually release the other side
here okay
how does that feel really good
okay good so now you do the other side
here
take your belly button and just go right
to the side of it and you want to go see
how i'm rocking left and right and you
just find the spot
find the sweet spot where it's like oh
that's a little thing that's smart and
you just now don't do this with a knife
okay
don't do that with a sharp object
use it the massage tool
that i'm i'm just joking
it's delayed
humor here
but it'll um
you want to use something that's kind of
like a dull point
and um
okay and then you just kind of inch up a
little bit
a little sore yeah so this is something
he would need to do every single night
and to the point where there's no
soreness and he would find that his
ability to relax like recently i saw
this so i was watching this movie um
it was um lincoln i mean here's a guy
who his dad beat him
growing up his mom died i think his
sister and his brother died
and then his first wife or first love
died
and then his several of his kids died i
mean like you imagine how many losses
this guy had right and then he becomes
the president which is a no stress job
i mean he was i think 50 i'm 53 he was
like 53 he looked like
a grandfather he was like old
so stress believe it or not does age you
i'm going to put some ears give you some
gray hairs especially if you have kids
so um
this basically kind of pulls the stress
out so you can
go back in the life and recharge and
start over again because you don't want
to just keep carrying the stress around
your whole life might as well kind of
have a blank slate clean it out because
our bodies are sponges and we pick up
stress
i think he's actually asleep did you
fall asleep
did you fall asleep yeah i did got it
see it worked
and he did it to himself i didn't do
anything
yeah so this is a really
amazing
um
so
a lot of you guys watching already have
the tool because i actually hear the
success if you don't have this tool you
need to get it
um because i fly everywhere i go i
travel i bring it with me and the plane
i do my neck points because you sit on
these these
these little i mean you flew to
california right and you're trying to
with your neck get this thing out sit
back and just kind of just
like i have people like where did you
get that can i borrow that i'm like no
i'm like i'm going to keep it on my neck
so it's good for that and also for jet
lag because you can actually work on
these points and kind of rejuvenate
yourself
okay then we come to this point come
this point like right through in here
is that a little sore
yeah
yeah and then uh he's gonna work on that
and then what'll happen is you're gonna
feel like um you're gonna take layers of
this stuff off and it could take a while
um and if you had like a fight with your
spouse
you could find that you can like
put the stress back in but at least you
have the tool to pull it out
you said throw it at them
no
you have the tool
as not as a weapon but as a therapy to
help yourself so you can sleep so you're
not
thinking about it all night long
or you can throw it at them too
yeah um
it's plastic it won't break don't worry
about it
i'm just kidding you don't want to throw
it on your spouse
okay good so now
tell me just sit up for me for a second
face the camera
how do you feel
a little light-headed but i feel a lot
better yeah
do you feel like stress more stress-free
yeah i do awesome i feel more relaxed
yes
that is the goal thank you we did it
okay appreciate it
thank
you now i'm going to show you how to do
it on yourself
all right so we're going to show you how
to do this on yourself you need a device
like this this is
built
after my own hand
okay and this is great for different
sizes of people look at the real wide
one here this is for the top part of the
neck
this is for different parts of the neck
this is for different size people we're
going to take the widest one on myself
hook it on the back of my neck scoot
this down on a tall back chair or the
couch
i think this works better
than using it on on your pillow when
you're going to sleep at night
because you're at a certain angle and
you can apply you can sit back and just
let these points
press right into your neck and there's a
sweet spot that you want to hit
that you'll just feel like the maximum
release of stress and you'll just want
to take a nap
i fell asleep
sometimes i'll do this on my desk i'll
put my feet up
and i'll sit back and i will just like
go right out this is like the most
important
acupressure point for your entire spine
to feel relaxed and to melt
because you're hitting
a point called the parasympathetic
the origin of the parasitic nervous
system which is right there
and that's the turn off switch that's
like the rest and digest that's your
relaxation
points
and then you do that for a little while
and then you come down
to the next point through here
second one
and i had a history of a lot of neck
problems so i do this a lot to keep my
neck nice and relaxed
okay then i'll inch down
to the middle part like
c5 and this is again really good for um
tension in your upper your upper
shoulders
and also good for your believe it or not
it's going to help your voice
yeah hoarseness
because
what you're doing is you're putting uh
stimulating
uh these points that
bring circulation to the entire
front part of your neck
and i always tell people don't believe
me just do it and just tell me what you
feel
uh be skeptical and uh see if it prove
it to yourself and uh nine out of ten
times it seems to work so
you should try it
okay
so that's so you want to start with this
first one second third fourth and just
kind of like ease down to the lower part
of your neck okay so that's how you do
the neck point
now this one here you wanna go right up
underneath the clavicle
collarbone and you're
gonna stretch back like this
what i like to do is i like to take the
longer part and come on the outside
and
stretch it lift and stretch
okay and you're just you're going to do
this on both sides right up underneath
the clavicle
so you're taking the upper
part of your chest you're taking the
upper part of your chest
and you're lengthening it you're getting
you're expanding it so now your neck
becomes very relaxed
so if you have tension in the back part
of your neck you want to work on the
front part right down here
if you've had a whiplash injury and you
do this you're going to have so much
relief it's going to be crazy this is
really because when you get a whiplash
that's with all the scar tissue that's
where a lot of the scar tissue kind of
develops but no one ever address
addresses those points so you want to
just
take right underneath the clavicle and
just stretch it out
okay
now we showed you how to do the abdomen
points okay which we call them adrenal
points you can work on that you can do
that
i recommend doing that in your bed
when you're lying down so you can be
comfortable
now for the mid back it's a little more
difficult to do this um but it's
actually not that bad if you do it on
your bed at night
you this is a tripod okay
and what i like to do is i like to take
the medium point
and i put this
underneath my
my body
okay i'm laying in bed with my pillow
right i put this in the lower part of my
spine
so this my spine the middle of my spine
is right here and i'm laying down
so i'll lay on these two points and
what's cool is that the the mattress is
soft enough where it squishes in
so it doesn't like because if i did it
in that table that i worked on those
other people with it would be it would
be too invasive
so on your your mattress it's better
because you can lay back on it so i take
it i put it in my back and i guess the
camera person can see that can you see
that okay
and i lean back like this and so the
cushion takes most of the slack
and i'll just lay there until the points
where i'm like oh my gosh that feels so
good and then i'll take my hand now
watch how i do this i inch it up
and i lay back down
on my bed
so i'm like to the left and right side
of my spine i'm going to hit every
single vertebra going up so it's kind of
like a wonderful
massage
okay but with sustained pressure
okay now go up a little bit
and of course i'm doing on this chair
and you can do it on a chair too and you
lean back and you're basically
hitting the left and right side of the
body it's not just about the muscles
you're working on something called the
autonomic nervous system back there and
it tends to relax
the whole front part as well so i'll do
that point and i might lay there for
like i don't know 30 seconds and i'll
inch up
until i go all the way up here in my
spine
and so what i'll do is if my arm can't
go back high enough
i'll position and i'll lay back on the
point and i'll just put my body over
those two points
and
if you saw with those other people i was
kind of bending their head back
you can put this on a chair and actually
lean back
your head like this
and you're stretching
that ligament
on the front of the spine and giving you
a lot of relief okay
so i can also
do this
i can just kind of like
kind of let it slip down right here and
you can
i can let it slip down and just
do this right right here
so that that way you get your mid-back
okay
you can do your neck
do up underneath the clavicle
and your points right through in here
okay
there's a there's a couple other things
you can do it's in the manual but those
are the the main points right there so
if you don't have this tool you need to
get one um it's awesome you can travel
with it it lasts forever it will not
break
and if you don't like it you can send it
back with it it's like a 60-day
money-back guarantee
anyway
i have a little
discount down below if you want to click
and get 10 off you can do that and then
there's two other products that i'm
going to talk about one is the sleep aid
okay so
i take one of these before i go to bed
it's it has certain nutrients to support
the adrenal glands
to help
pull stress out of your body more from a
nutritional angle
it doesn't give you a groggy feeling in
the morning but it does help the quality
of sleep so if you really have a lot of
stress or sleeping problems
this might really help you in addition
to the tool
massage tool
there's also a vegan version as well
but this the regular version does have
adrenal
extracts in it so adrenal gland extract
but it seems to work great i like the
formula i like actually both of them i
take both of them and they both work
equally
so you just need one before bed and
you'll sleep pretty good
the other
product that i recommend for stress
would be the adrenal and cortisol relief
this is good for the daytime
some people take six a day some people
take three a day spread out you can take
them with or without meals you're going
to feel very calm when you take this
it'll help you give you energy but
mainly it's for stress your tolerance
for stress will be much better so this
supports adrenal from different angles
and if you have a lot of built up of
like nervous energy this is wonderful
you'll feel like within a few minutes
you'll just feel stress free so you can
get all three of these products in a kit
get the adrenal cortisol support the
night formula and the massage tool in a
kit or get them individually depending
on what you want and what you need all
right guys so thank you so much for
listening in on this webinar and lasting
this long i really appreciate your
attention i can't wait to hear the
results from
you applying this to someone else and
yourself
definitely share that with me alright
we'll see you later